I love dance parties.
When does it start?
Hmm.
Right now.
(RAPPING) Shake.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
Whoo.
Shake that fuzz.
Shake that fur.
You got it.
Let's go.
Shake that fuzz.
Shake that fur.
You can shake it.
Cool.
Shake that fuzz.
Shake that fur.
Ring-a-ding.
Here comes another customer.
Helpsters ready at the
counter with the cure.
Never heard a beat this
pure, so shake that fuzz,
shake that fur.
Uh.
Cody, Heart, Scatter, Mr. Primm.
Yes, sir.
The plan is we're gonna
shake it like a Helpster.
Better move the furniture
and shake that fuzz,
shake that fur.
Come on.
You can shake it.
Shake that fuzz.
Shake that fur.
This is so great!
(RAPPING) You got a lot of fur.
When does it end?
(RAPPING) Shake that fuzz.
Right now.
Oh.
Right on time.